oh that hurt big-time now you idiot so
good okay
hey I'm Chris Thalia and these are my
favorite YouTube videos so this is a
one-of-a-kind piece there's no other one
like this particular one in the world my
favorite YouTube video ever you can see
the tracks go this way
it's this guy showing this tech thing
and right after he says that it's a
one-of-a-kind thing it just basically
kind of explodes but oh he goes to say
and he stops himself because he's on TV
and instead he says [ __ ] which is also a
bad word oh my god oh he was on this TV
show where it was like you want to show
him this really special thing and now it
doesn't exist are you doing without yeah
I'm done with that alright another video
I like on YouTube is called a home
shopping ladder blooper you just push
the button then right here on on the two
sides the two little buttons home
shopping networks always have the best
cops because it's such a funny thing
already because people are selling
things that they don't give a [ __ ] about
and this is tough it is listen give you
an example it's like this ladder it's
the worst ladder ever obviously just
walk right up and I tell you it's very
safe so the dudes walking up the ladder
he's telling you how it's supposed to
lock in place and then the ladder gives
a little bit and it goes like that
they're locked in place and he's scared
of [ __ ] but he is on TV so he's like
okay see now it's locked in place oh I
didn't have a lock and then it cuts to
the stock footage of the ladder so sad
but so funny because this the idiot has
to sell this ladder that he knows sucks
but it is very safe to operate I will
just actually sit and watch the Home
Shopping Network waiting for these cops
but this one was the samurai fail 18:16
is the item number on this one where the
guy who is selling this sword that he
probably knows nothing about talking
about how sturdy this sword is and he's
banging it against the table like a
[ __ ] and the nice thing about these
practice guitarists
Oh oh that hurt Oh it got me that hurt
big-time a piece of that just the tip
just got me O'Dell yeah piece of that
just got me no [ __ ] like we all saw you
get stabbed by a samurai sword
we may need emergency surgery in the
studio I'm Christa Lia and thanks for
listening to me talking about my
favorite videos on YouTube oh I honestly
think I was crying all day because I
kept watching the video and I wouldn't
not laugh at it